six month old Matthew sits on his
mother's lap a researcher sits opposite
and keeps his attention on a colorful
toy while a tape plays two sounds one is
baa and the other is da a sound only
used in Hindi and one which most
english-speaking listeners can't
distinguish from the English sound da
during the initial training period a toy
bunny is lit up in a large glass box to
the side of Matthew the instant the da
sound is played when the bass sound is
played the bunny stops and Matthew turns
back to the researcher the routine
continues until Matthew learns to
associate the change from ba to da with
the bunny
Matthew even turns his head in
anticipation when the researchers delay
the bunnies appearance matthew is now
ready for the test phase of the
experiment a new tape is played this
time with two different da sounds that
are only used in Hindi even though they
are two completely different sounds an
adult who can't speak Hindi doesn't hear
the difference but Matthew immediately
turns his head towards the button when
he hears the change from one Hindi da to
the other although he has never heard
Hindi spoken researchers recognized that
at six months he is still the universal
listener able to distinguish all sounds
Emma who is four months older than
Matthew has come to the lab for the
first time after a similar training
routine is Matthew she's presented with
the same problem of distinguishing the
two different Hindi da sounds
but at this age Emma whose parents speak
only English doesn't react when there is
a change from one to the other she is
more interested in the toy in front of
her than the bunny this leads the
researchers to conclude that by 10
months the baby humans stops being the
universal listener and like the adult of
the species no longer hears the
difference between the two sounds